you know happy st patrick's day
if you get sunburned easily or you
or if somebody slaps you everybody can
tell
then this this holiday is for you
if you if dogs get angry at you
sometimes when they see you
because it can be a little a little
shocking
you know just the um the contrast or
you know the contrast of of uh
just the reflection
coming off you sometimes can do that
then this holiday is for you
happy st patrick's day if two or three
minutes in the sun can absolutely
put you in the hospital maybe and maybe
even affect your dna
so that your children and
great-great-grandchildren and everyone
you know
ends up being addicted to alcohol then
this holiday
is for you happy st patty's day everyone
saint patty what are some famous saints
they had
let me look at some famous saints
they had anthony
joseph oh joseph was always trying to
saint your sister down you know what i'm
saying boy you know little joseph bro
he sneak over dude put a handful of work
in uh dirty holy water in your sister's
in your sister's mouth you know trying
to get her to freaking uh
do some freebasing or whatever but um
who else did they have michael the
archon michael the arch
angel peter and then they had patty
do you know saint patty was like
i'm not gonna say that
she was probably trying i'm guessing
probably transgender if you go back
to you know
the past then it's probably saint patty
was definitely trans
you know there comes saint patty
same patty give you a little
butterscotch give you a little handful
of mint
you know put a little um
molasses under your tongue man we used
to have this guy that worked at our
middle school named mr rubin
and he was named after probably the meat
the sandwich meat
and he um
and he he would put a little molasses
under your tongue baby
you know when he saw you he'd keep him a
little dropper like one of them squirrel
feeders
and when he saw you if you was kind of
being loud or something he'd hit you
with that glasses baby
he just died just douse you up
and you couldn't help but feel good
molasses it's kind of
it's sweet and also kind of earthy
kind of sour kind of urban
a little bit canadian but also a little
has just a mild
kind of mapley
japanese kind of after
you know kind of um repast or something
vibe you know but um
anyway happy saint patty's day man a lot
of people out there
uh the irish and they're good man the
irish if you see the irish they're
usually doing something
sometimes they just get so plastered
they don't even
you know and you're like oh man is that
guy okay and people are like yeah yeah
man that guy's irish bro
you know let him celebrate baby so this
is your day man
um thank you guys for being here with me
today and uh and for getting into this
episode
it is the year two zero two one
and we are traveling through space and
time in unison
and this is our time
this is grady spencer and the work
you always who keeps
together you always are the one who
knows just what we need
you always are the one who stays home
with your baby you gonna be
the one who stays right here with me
so we
baby you know you're so pretty
and i don't know how to baby your
mind this is our time
this is our time that is greatest
spencer
and the work and that's their album
you know they do a song and they and you
know it's amazing somebody makes a song
and then you get to enjoy it
and that's called transmission
um happy st patrick's you know happy st
patty and happy everybody named patty
everybody that's ever been patted on the
back
everybody that's ever had a patch on
their uh pants
um you know everybody who's ever
attempted a point after touchdown
i i commend you i commend you all on
this beautiful day to enjoy the color
green
i said sean says sean he gets you know
get a little something
step up the studio we got a couple of
these look like florida plants a little
something from florida and uh
we got that vibe we got a little bitty
hat
okay somebody come through this kind of
small headed
and um what's up
went to jiu jitsu today uh
man what something well
i'll be honest with you man they had me
fight it's not going well
i'll say that um
i have uh tapped out to
fighters women fighters you know
females they call them females but as
far as i'm concerned once you get in the
um
in the dodgeo dog it's all it's mono
imano you know
leave your tits at the door boo boo it's
you know we both going toe to toe here
it doesn't matter everybody got a wiener
in here that's how i look at it
so but the crazy part they made me like
fight a
i guess a blind guy and this guy's blind
bro legally blind or
or illegally blind i guess i don't know
which one he is
i haven't seen like his prison record
and stuff but he's blind
so it's kind of crazy because i'll just
be real quiet
and they say that's cheating so it's
like
i don't know you learn as you go i'm
just grateful to be in there
i hurt one of my wrists so bad though i
couldn't even wipe my buttocks man
if i was doing number two doing a duty
i couldn't put enough pressure
on to the tissue
i just could it was like uh
you know i just couldn't do it so then i
had to wipe my buttocks with the
alternate hand
which uh i don't know if you've ever
done
that but it's
first of all it's very scary i didn't
even know
how to do it it's kind of like when
somebody
has you shoot a free throw or something
with your oppo
opposing hand you know if somebody has
you use your
use your opposite hand dude you it's
scary right it feels like you feel like
you feel like kind of blind in your arm
or something you feel like your whole
arm is blind
you know it just you can't do it you
can't uh
you just can't you can't do it man
so that that uh that's something that's
tricky man
you know that's something that even mr
rubin with a couple freaking baby bird
droppers that have
that molasses can't handle and can heal
um so anyway yeah just been going
through a lot of aches and pains with
that
and dealing with that and just getting
through it fighting the blind
fighting the females bro you know
um it's uh yeah
they you know they're very accepting of
me over there they work with me
uh it's just harder your body gets older
it gets harder you gotta make sure
everything
here's what i noticed about getting
older
i noticed when i jump
somewhere i have to look
where i'm jumping i used to just
jump i would jump i would land i'm going
i'm already on to the next whatever it
is
but now it's like if i'm say i'm going
for a jog or something i'm gonna jump
over something
um there's a couple seconds of planning
it's like almost like a quarter block of
planning okay
when i get up here i'm gonna do this
jump and it's not it's not even anything
big it's like a little it's like
two sticks that have somehow
found their way together two sticks or a
you know a little um
see herb or something curb
you know and so i
uh but i was like all right here we go
here we go
okay yeah and it's so it just it's so
much more i think we're in the
when you was a child you'd run and jump
over something you didn't know
you jump over it and keep going never
even thought twice or even once about it
but different times man um
i got a home i got a place
i'm keeping my place in los angeles i
got a place out here in the central east
so i'm going to experiment with that
it's exciting but nerve-wracking
um but it's kind of nice it's like you
can
it's a things are a little more chill
and then things are a little bit more
uh when i go to los angeles and it's for
if i want to go there for a month or if
i want to work on something or
you know we're doing podcasting whatever
it's great it's kind of nice to be able
to be in different places
so i'm real grateful to have that
ability
and ability is just
that's just when you can do something
and you
it's not even when you then do it it's
just when you can do something
so there's a lot of ability out there
that never
gets acted on which is kind of wild
really
um but i went
over there the other night and i like
because the pla
the the place closed yesterday and i
went over there
and man i like walked in
and i was like i was almost kind of
spooked out
it was like all right i guess uh
and i didn't even stay i just came back
to the airbnb that i've been over at
you know it feels like i don't know i
guess it feels like maybe you should
have like a family or something or maybe
it feels like you should have
there should be some other level oh
i don't know i think i need to get some
groceries
that will help me get more acclimated
so but those are some things that are
going
on or have been um
what else oh i went to a basketball game
i went to the
lsu was playing in the
um sec tournament
and i really love lsu basketball
my fr my father was friends with dale
brown when he was
i don't know when they were children and
dale brown's like an old coach of lsu
and
anyway um
anyway so i'll go down to the game i
took a date
took a date go down to the game
and first of all
i did i didn't have uh tickets i didn't
have any entry
entry certificates you know so i'm
thinking i got to get so you know i got
i need to
hit one of these uh vendors a vendor
and so i go and a man they got a big
fella out there and the dude was pretty
it was kind of an urban dude you know
what i'm saying like kind of like
seemed black and so
he was eating something he was polishing
off something he was a big guy he
reminded me of
um baloo i think
blue bear let me look him yes
he had that feet uh that physique that
same
physique baby that p hyzek as
baloo from the jungle book
very uh like lean
like kind of like well look first of all
if you've been to an sec event or
something there's a lot of
country people there so a lot of people
resembled a kind of a snowman-esque
or melted snowman
you know that body style where it was
just
somebody wearing a 9xl t-shirt
with no pants just totally it went it
went down to their shoes and then they
just
kind of tied it off at the bottom you
know just
a lot of unique body styles very
plush i would say overall
you know i'd say kind of um flammable
type of body you know real
soft real flammable body style
um anyway so this fella we go over and
trying to get some tickets and i should
have just got him before i go
and the man name was sherlock
okay the man name was sherlock and he
said oh my
my brother has him yard boy
so the second he said yard boy i could
see my date
was kinda she wasn't real sure about
i think probably the way i operate
i would say maybe she was
she knew that thing this was getting
interesting and this wasn't the type of
interesting she wanted you know
her like for her probably her you know
and you know i think as inter
anyway so she so anyway we got we start
walking down the street
so we see yard boy right and he
basically looks
just like the guy he looks just like
sherlock and sherlock was eating
something man or he had crumbs built in
around his mouth
like but it looked like he'd been cross
salting you know like he'd been uh
french snacking you know what i'm saying
he had that big
that big baby bear look where he he's
definitely stuck his head into a bakery
window
and kind of had his way while the
cashier
was in the restroom you know what i'm
saying
so anyway uh sherlock is doing his thing
and then we meet up with your
boy and yard boy is from
i want to say jamaica maybe but that's
also just me
guessing because if i hear any sort of
island sound my brain immediately goes
yamika you know
place a bed with me welcome to jamaica
which reminds me actually i was in i
don't even know if it was jamaica one
time could have been uh
dominican republic or uh
trinidad or somewhere dang i'm saying
panty
it could have been uh somewhere like
that and
we're walking down the street and they
had
a starbucks on
so we go in we're students we go into
the place
and we walk in and there's a lady in the
back she goes welcome to the starbucks
lounge
can i get you a smoothie
and we're like where are we and they had
stole or borrowed a stolen or borrowed
a starbucks sign just put it up in front
of their business out front
so people are venturing in and it's not
even a starbuck
they had smoothie but
um anyway so y'all boys there
and then uh so they your boy goes oh i
don't have them pop has them right
so we got sherlock and sherlock started
to kind of like
um i want to say exasperate or something
at this point he started to
he was having a breathing issue you know
and sure like i don't even know why they
call him sherlock
i mean this dude couldn't found this
dude couldn't have found his breath
if it wasn't built into his damn lung
system you know he couldn't find his
name
this dude couldn't have found his blood
if it wasn't built into his veins
so anyway sherlock and uh yard boy
they say pop got some so now we look
down the street the way we had just come
it's been about four minutes now
and there is a man pop i guess
apparently pop
walking down towards them and there's
tons of people walking
it's outdoors and some people are coming
up and saying hey man can i get a photo
or saying hey you know
you know i love your podcast stuff like
that or and it's real nice it's just
it's a lot going on because i'm starting
to wonder like is things legitimate here
with um with yard boy and sherlock
which i think is a very normal question
for any natural man to ask themselves at
a certain point
i've just spent 250 dollars here
are things okay with yard boy
and sherlock
so at this point you see the people
coming and i said where is he i mean
we're waiting another two minutes
he said he right there manny right there
we doing business man we doing business
and i'm trying to be supportive you know
uh
and then finally i start to see the guy
there is one guy
he's wearing parkas blue
kind of um parka plastic for raining
it's not raining
he's on two of those and he has on
everybody else is walking at a
considerable speed
this guy pop sorry
is walking at the speed of
hope he's walking at the speed of a
rumor
like there's no like oh and here's the
worst part
he had have you seen those air cast
people have like a air cast on her leg
it has like a little hole by the knee
like a
look like a little birdhouse door on it
he has one of those on each leg
it should say on the box when you get
a air cast soft cast for
one leg it should say hey
you can't wear one of these on your
other leg
at the same time but it doesn't say that
so here he comes dude this little
freaking teapot
you know i'm a little teapop
sword and stout this
this guy and my dad hates me
she's literally at this point i can feel
her texting whatever the last guy she
went out with
just probably asking this man to come
pick her up
um
anyway so pop finally gets there he
don't have the tickets he said
he don't know what happened it's a
sailor tower issue bro
okay look
when this dude says it's a cellular
tower issue i cuz i'm
now it's it's been 11 minutes we don't
have tickets it's so it's just
you know the college basketball is a
short game a short game there's two
20-minute halves so i can feel the
halves going down
and i just said look just give me my
money back
and uh they said well look come inside
with this we'll walk you in
we try to do that for five more minutes
it's a nightmare they're on the phone
and every time i say look man this is
just you know can i just
we're done the guy's like it's a uh
sherlock said
it's a cellular tower issue man
like i don't give a what it is
if i sell you something but i don't have
something
then that's on you big dog um
anyway i don't know why i told you that
story but yeah it was not uh
was not a good date uh it was just bad
it was just
it was too much it was stressful
that's why you got to get the tickets
before
you got to plan ahead and you got to get
the tickets before so
that's kind of where i'm at um
oh here was the worst part
when pop finally got up there
him or each time we met with somebody
when yard boy
and sherlock they did a handshake it was
like a
40 second handshake dude
it was like a hit like they were in the
super bowl like they were wide receivers
on the pittsburgh steelers and they
wasn't doing
uh yo pop dude had two
i think he dislocated his entire lower
body
bro you could see when the wind would
blow a little it almost cost him
his life every time
birds were landing on him he had hay
coming out of his shirt sleeves you know
they had drawn freckles on his cheeks
they you know
anyway oh jesus christ
and i was so few by the end of it all i
was so furious it was like an
hour total nightmare
so anyway get the tickets before you go
man that's what i'm trying to tell you
today um i want to let you know that
the zebra is out there
you know and it's a time in the world
where we want to support uh
diversity and nothing does that better
than the zebra
that's god's mixed baby right there
and when you use the zebra.com
insurance finally feels like it's in
black and white
no more of this vague insurance
no more confusion just honest honest
rates from real companies you're not
gonna get
uh gary's insurance and your car breaks
down and some dude named gary come pick
you up
and he got his sister with him because
she's going in the uh
attraction i mean come on come on
the zebra is a nation's leading
insurance comparison site for car and
home insurance
they can help you save money today it's
so easy go to thezebra.com and answer a
few questions
to compare accurate insurance quotes for
free
the zebra protects your personal
information and make sure there are no
hidden fees or surprises
along the way how much money can you
save on car
or home insurance visit the zebra.com
t-h-e-o that's e b
r t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a dot com slash theo
for insurance in black and white
support the podcast and get out there
and get insured
get insured um
well we got some nice we got some
exciting things i think in this episode
pretty excited about that uh the new be
good to yourself hoodies
are out some unique um color pairings
and uh they're almost sold out but
they'll be back in stock soon
we have the original be good to yourself
hoodie back in stock this week
we also have the new get that hitter
merch so check that out as well
um and uh what else do we have
what else can i tell you about
what else is going on uh
well being in a new home is just i don't
know i'm not even in there yet
and just yeah i'm not even in there yet
so we'll see
we'll see what it's like it feels like i
guess it feels kind of scary
i've never i've always
been a bit more ability to ramble
and be that dusk in the wind
and uh dusk in the women you got no you
know you
you really just hook your coat onto the
breeze
so i think there's probably some nerves
when it comes into um
when it comes into having like some a
little bit more establishment
uh but it'll be fun you know i think
there'll be some other stuff will be
nice getting groceries
um you know in waters like in a cupboard
where you're going to always have waters
um what else have a drawer where you
keep this you keep that
you know you need tape you need
electrical tape
you know you want to keep a paint set
you want to keep um
a friend have an extra bedroom keep them
you know just having that ability to do
different stuff and have a little bit of
space in that sort of thing
so
what else do we have man uh
you know let's get into a little bit of
news uh
right here uh bill burr
upset people at the grammys they said
and i saw what he said and he didn't he
didn't really upset anyone
he didn't really even say much really um
and you know what i started to realize
what's going on a lot in the news these
days is a reverse
uh psychology
basically
you know billboard didn't really say
anything
but suddenly there's an uproar and then
it becomes a thing but the uproar is
just created because
uh that way people go see the clip right
we know that kind of stuff
people go see the club whether it
happened or not
but then i started to think like as some
bigger stuff you know i started to think
about um
the dr seuss thing
and here's my theory on dr seuss
for one i started to think that
i bet i bet someone had a lot of dr
seuss books
that the sales on them had probably
slowed down
because i don't know if people are
buying as dr seuss as much
you ask kid these days if who dr seuss
is they think it's an actual doctor they
think it's an indian guy
let's be honest so um
i think the big deal is somebody i bet
probably had too many doctors whose
books they couldn't sell them company
whatever
so they said well let's let's create
this blurb let's create this hubbub
let's make it so that oh these these
books are going to get discontinued
let's influence whoever we can to get
these books discontinued or banned or
whatever
so then suddenly everyone goes and buys
the dr seuss books
now everybody's cat in the head it up
everybody's hammed and greened
you know and everybody's hearing
horton's in the distance you know it is
what it is
but now they've sold more books than
ever just because so people can be like
why you know
so the whole thing is just a trick
really
whoever's discontinued the books they
don't really care
in the end they're just trying to sell
some books
i think the same thing was true with the
mr potato head they said oh mr potato
they're just trying to sell
plastic vegetables bro
that's it no one re it's all a trick
once they have us clicking on whatever
boom
then we've already then our time our
attention
you know once you give your attention to
something that's it because that's your
value
is your attention
um so anyway yeah billboard didn't say
anything
and if you looked at the clip he didn't
say anything oh some cis white male i
didn't give
it seemed ridiculous the the category
they haven't given him but it just
whatever you know
i like it he went out it was just kind
of him in the brief moment he could be
there wasn't a ton of opportunity for
him uh
to really emphasize his personality
but yeah but yeah it's all a trick man
then you got then now you got the book
and now you're you're standing your
ground
but it's just getting weirder
they you know you tear down the statue
chair i'm just trying to get rid of
history i just don't understand why you
just don't leave history where it is
it's already gone
but what else
man oh i saw this article tennessee man
leaves
five million dollars to dog in his
will she's a good girl
that's what he said i'll tell you more
about it in just a second i want you to
know that uh
grub hub is where it's at if you
you know you've you've been you know
you've been alive for a certain amount
of years and
you've been eating and you know you've
been eating man i've seen you
i saw a big sherlock and he had them
little french crisps out there around
his mouth hole
around that big heaty heaty pie hole
bruh he could have had a dang bird
living up in his in
in his face he was tall you know
and a bird i could easily see he had tan
skin that bird land in him
and do an egg or something in his ear
but what i'm telling you about is uh
grub hub
perks get deals on the food you love if
you already use
food apps a lot then use the one that's
going to give you
dang resilience and and uh
rewards grubhub perks grubhub
has all the food you love from your
favorite local restaurants man get what
you want man
get you an olive garden baby get you a
jerry's little uh
uh ice cream get you a freaking
reginald's taco bro
you know what i'm saying get what you
want you know
big sows um hot pocket
get what you want some places offer
special things
you want to eat uh baked beans out of a
fleshlight maybe there's a place that
can do it
well grubhub will help you
you want to eat a hot custard out of a
newborn babies ball cap
there might be a place that could help
it help you make that happen
and grubhub is going to be working with
them
with grubhub all the local restaurants
in your area
they're on there you can try a variety
of cuisines order ahead and pick up your
favorite food
from your favorite restaurants on
grubhub get the food you love with perks
from grub hub grub
what you love take a break from cooking
grow pub a little hot girl have a little
alright so more in the news
um a tennessee man
named bill doris leave five
million dollars to his dog
he said she's a good girl
man man
that's hard to stomach man
hell that's hard to cow stomach and they
got eight stomachs
just the fact that that's what we get
that's what we get humans the way we
want to treat each other
then now the money go to the animal you
want to light your grandmother's
uh little cat's tail on fire we're gonna
see who gets the last laugh now aren't
we
when biscuit gets that inheritance
and suddenly you know you working for a
dalmatian somewhere
times have changed man i'm telling you
you got to start treating your
grandparents well
oh you don't want to eat nana's banana
bread
well guess who is eating it little petey
it's going it's going to be wild when
you're living in a bird cage for the
rest of your life
and petey's out there on his computer
all day on his ameritrade account
it's just where we're at it's where
we're at as people man
one more news beat here
scientists if you believe in them
want to send 335 million
seed sperm and egg samples to the moon
to create a lunar noah's ark
that's what it's come down to folks we
are we're basically
jerking off into space spraying out
busting heavy out into the atmosphere
what's going on just be honest we're
trying to get rid of ginger
seed it's been highly reported that for
decades nobody's been buying that ginger
bust over there at the sperm account
and so times have changed man
times have changed and now they gotta
send it out into space hopefully it
knocks up an alien
that's crazy man some cyborg rolls up
looking like uh banta remember
banta from uh superheroes or whatever
what is that thing called banta from
oh blanca
from street fighter
yup gonna be a bunch of blancas out
there boy
gonna be a bunch of blancas out there
but that's how desperate we are
you know nobody wants that ginger bust
i mean probably the last two gangs i
know or even
this fella andrew santino a young
comedian and um
andy dalton who's playing for chicago
bears now
so it's a wild world man
but yeah they we we jerking out into
space now
hoping to knock up a damn moon or
something
it's gonna be funny nine months from now
you're gonna see a moon just
a leg pop out of the moon a lil ween or
a low ivory
different times different times i'm
going to tell you right now if you are
aren't taking care of your body or your
penis
you can you can
blue chew has silda nafl
and tata lawful tablets and they
are chewable blue chews tablets are made
in the usa and they prepare and ship
direct so it's cheaper than a pharmacy
when i was young if you wanted to get
erect you had to go you know
you had to run outside put your dick in
the sun you had to do different things
with your wiener your penis bro
you know you had to do you had to just
be wild man
hang your penis out the window while
y'all's driving let that wind hit it
get that wind rod huh pop heavy off that
breeze daddy
but times have changed man and now
there are services like blue chew
blue chews tablets help men achieve
harder stronger erections to combat all
forms of ed
which means erectile dysfunction
i knew a fellow man in our neighborhood
he apparently he rolled over in bed once
in his penis fell off the bed
his erection and broke the back of a
full-grown cat
so that's the power of that rod baby
spare the rod save the child you know
that
don't molest baby here's a special deal
for our listeners try bluetooth free
when you use our promo code t-h-e-o at
checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w
dot com promo code theo to receive your
first month free
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast
what else man i want to ask you guys if
you guys know about some funny videos or
things you want to send in send them in
if you want to nominate a single mom for
our uh
you know to help and you know we try to
help out and stuff if you want to
nominate a single mom for that
you can send either of those to
tpwproducer
gmail.com or go to theovon.com
there's a spot to upload a fan upload
link
and you can upload videos there
a little bit of liquid death on that
saint patty's day
man i got a new house i'm excited you
know i think some of us hit me i think
there's some fear but i'm just you know
it'd be nice get like a little
get a hamper you know get some stuff
that you're going to keep
you know most of my life has just been
very transient
um it's hard for me to commit to stuff
i mean i'll even go do a yoga session or
something at a gym
and they offer you that 10 pack and it's
cheaper or something and i won't do it i
can't commit to 10 sessions man even if
it's over the course of a year
i like to get that one session it's
manageable
you know so i'm curious to see kind of
uh you know some of what will come from
having um
that homestead experience
one more news panda express employee
forced to strip during trust building
exercise
look lady you know it's
i mean look when people want that panda
they want it fast you feel me that's
what i'm saying boo boo
we've all been molested lady you know i
want to be there for you but at this
point everybody's been molested and over
molested
re-molested unmolested oh
you know people have been molested
mo molested molested you know it's just
it's all you know no matter what
industry you're in
you're gonna get molested i hate to say
that but if you at the movie industry
you know
harvey weptstein is molesting people uh
larry johnson uh bill clinton
you know um
you know joseph biden smelling children
somebody's got to get apparently
apparently
look at game of thrones half the show
people's getting molested
so apparently you know whether you in
sports or whatever
and i'm not saying justifying and i'm
just saying lady that it
you know i'm sorry
you know but we've all got a i mean i i
got a close family member
you know that suffers from addiction of
drugs and alcohol because
they used to have to go horseback riding
with with a fellow you know
we was just trying to make pizzas over
there
so everybody's gotta you know
everybody's getting molested really
somehow i got a uh
i know a friend who was a straight man
you know or he was he was straight at
the time and he
might still be straight
so that's up to him and god but it's um
he he was trying to get a job at a hair
salon he wanted to be the last straight
hair man and he was they had two men
that made him do
cocaine with glitter in it
you know outside of an old town concert
up there near um
liberty out there near liberty new york
outside of rochester
so and they tried to touch his ass and
everything in his booty hole booty pipe
so it's all you know that's work if you
want to work you know i hate to say it
but every
anywhere you look people are getting
touched or touched out
so that's that's unfortunately that's
big business
you know it's very sad
it's very sad but i mean hell half my
friends have been busted for
you know are accused of sexually it's
just everybody so i'm not shocked if you
work at a panda express
if somebody's serving you know they got
you over there on that steamed rice
they trying to serve that freaking you
know
they trying to walk you up with that egg
roll you feel me boo boo
i'm just saying i'm not i'm just saying
i'm not
shocked if you over there slanging that
orange chicken
that every now and then people want a
little they want to huff on that
freaking uh
on that little booty monkey you feel me
on that little on that dirty monkey
so that's all i'm just saying i'm not
shocked all right
let's get into some calls man
oh we had some great calls that came in
here on the hotline
um let's get into it right now
this is zachary you up
from illinois what's up zachary
and look illinois man is uh
illinois is a good place to get diabetes
man while you work hard
some places it's diabetes only but you
guys will stay busy
and uh get the disease and so that's
pretty
you know hats off to you i don't have a
hat i'm a senior in high school this
year
and i'm in desperate need of a senior
quote and i thought who better to give
me a senior quote than the theo bond
so if you give me a funny one line or
some words of wisdom
for my senior quote that'd be great
thanks take care bye
well i could tell you straight up that
the road to the strap goes
through the rat you know that right
there baby boy
i think another good senior quote might
be
knock knock who's there
and that's it
and a lot of people are gonna be like
damn this guy something's wrong with
this guy
that's fine
that's fine man because it's just that
vague you know
it's that dirty oyster bruh
it's that easter oyster sometimes you
open up a an oyster around eastern it
got a little chocolate
in it you say damn how'd this little
shellfish get this sweet goodie but
that's god
that's that easter oyster baby
so that's what i would go with what do
you guys think that's a good question to
put out to the universe
and don't read any off of the internet
and come at me with those
because i thought about doing that
already but i thought i got to think
something up
so i thought knock knock who's there
i thought um
um
what else would be good
i never got to smoke crack
and that's a true statement for me but
it's something i've thought might be
nice to have in a yearbook just to kind
of
document where you are in your life
um
you could also just admit something that
happened
you know you know
just tell the truth about something i
hit a hot girl with my car when i was in
high school
and sometimes i don't really admit it
you know she was walking it wasn't you
know and
i feel bad but it's like we don't know
what god has in store
for us so you have to think about it
like that man
but good luck zachary and if you guys
have a recommendation for him
985-664-9503
um this tick tock came in of a
grandmother
let's see what she had to say get
something here to eat i won't
what's wrong with you you don't piss me
off taping me
don't be talking ugly
you ought to not be telling people my
damn business if i want to i can
you ain't nobody's business but
mine
amen to that amen that's five years ago
when
five years ago you might still be doing
that
why i'm too old no
so look right there you see uh
what's happening right here really and
this is unfortunate that this kind of
happens a lot of
older senior citizens are being used for
tick tock clout
and you see that a lot man and right
here grandma got birded down about 10
years ago or something five years ago
she was working at a panda express
obviously and uh
i don't wanna i should it
ain't nobody's business but mine
somebody wanted to freaking warm up that
pink monkey you feel me
and um that's what happened and i hate
to say that it's pretty
you know i feel pretty dirty saying it
um but
you know we all know what sex is and how
it happens
and that's insertion
so uh
yeah people blasting out their
grandparents so they could get that
clout that tick-tock
faint they're doing the same thing with
mentals on there
you know you'll scroll through a
tick-tock and next thing you know you
logged onto a couple of minnows
and there's some guy over there eating
out of a dog bowl or something
are they putting you know they beating
them with it you know
you know pillows you know they'll get
two minnows out there and have them
pillow fight
each other you know before they get on a
little bus or whatever and it's just
that's what people are getting off on i
guess
and build building their clout with
and some of this who knows how it can go
how it could end you know that's what i
wonder how does it
what's the long term you know when i was
young they had a group that would come
to our town it was called
fist fights and it was this was a
group that came through louisiana it was
gay men would fist fight each other
if i wanna i can it ain't
nobody's business but mine
and this isn't my term for it this is
what they called it this was a different
time where people were
you know it wasn't about the wording it
was about who people are and what's
happening
and there was a lot of love and support
in the air and we'd go out and pay five
dollars to go over there to the bar
and uh and watch these fellas arm down
baby
i mean watch these boys just knuckle out
um and you know obviously one of my best
friends was one of the
strongest gay uh fighters in america
ever named
billy conforto
and he passed away man and i i gotta
reach out to chucky over there and we
gotta get a bench for him
over there in slidell and we'll see what
we can do so i'm gonna do that this week
but um
yeah so anyway that's what's going on
grandma's pissed man because she's
trying to get that wing
that late wing and you start to wonder
as you get older what's the last hurrah
when you're gonna get that last butt
that last bust you know that last suckle
when do you think it's too old when do
you think you'll shut it down at six
and you can hit the hotline for that as
well 985-664-9503 when you're going to
shut down that sex that booty magic
you know when you're going to stop uh
doing that um that dirty david
copperfield you know put
out you know i'm pulling that rabbit out
of your cooch
gang baby damn um
you know what we got a
we got a really nice single mom
submission that came in right here you
know we are
you know always trying to do what we can
to help out the ladies that helped us
out
you know for those of you that were
raised by single moms
i want to thank my friend brittany too
mailed this shirt into me
and um so let's see let's see what we
got here that came in here's one
what's up theo my name is dalton i'm
from ventura california
i'm a huge fan of yours big dalton
what's up big dalton
and dalton is a name you might see like
a
dalton you might see somebody
say hey dalton hey dalton and that's you
let's hear it baby um i especially love
the things that you do for single moms
my sister alex is 31 years old she has a
beautiful four-year-old daughter named
cameron
and she's also a labor and delivery
nurse in june
she also found out that she had stage
four breast cancer
she's gone through 16 rounds of chemo as
well as just got her surgery done
over at ucla recently she's starting
radiation
in april um and i know a shout out from
you would mean the world to her
so i hope you guys have a good day i
appreciate you theo i appreciate you
nick as well man
love you guys gang brother thank you man
that's
nice yeah i see you there with your bj
uh with your brazilian jiu jitsu
shirts on and uh that's sweet that you
care about your sister so much man
you know um
you know it's amazing the magic that can
be kind of sewn between family
you know and i'm feeling a little bit
emotional at this moment but
you know there's just something special
about when we care about each other
you know and i just notice it there you
call you know uh
sorry one more time let me get this uh
what's up theo my name is dalton i'm
from ventura california and that's big
dalton right there
yeah there's just something special
dalton about when we care when we
just are honest about how we feel you
know you call you dishonest you say man
this is who i am this is who i care
about
and uh this is what's been going on with
her
and suddenly we can all feel that
you know there's just a real power and
vulnerability right there man
um let's call alex up man i'm sure she's
a nurse too she probably is busy
labor and delivery damn hope i don't
have any boy you feel me son
here we go
oh beautiful picture of the two of them
hello hey is alex in there
yes this is her hey alex my name is theo
i am a friend of
dalton's your brother he just wanted me
to give you a call i just work on
on a podcast and we do like a thing
where people
nominate like people that that they know
that are single moms that um
that we kind of reach out to theo
oh my god yeah theo yeah that creep
uh hey how are you today i'm doing good
how are you
oh i'm doing pretty good uh yeah dalton
he just loves you he said you work at
the labor and delivery place
that place yeah baby's dropping out like
life
that's crazy and what's going on with
them are they looking healthy you think
overall or give me really the low down
well right now they're having so i've
been out of work for
since july now wow on a medical leave
but from what i hear of all my friends
at work it's like all those quarantined
babies they're just booming and it's
insane really
yeah so people just locked up everyone's
locked up and yeah what are you gonna do
i guess i get frisky oh i guess man
that sounds fun it also sounds miserable
though i feel like
i don't know if you want to knock
something up that you still have to live
with for a long time that seems like the
scary part to me okay
well what i i was asking them and like
how many like you know kids you have to
be at first you had all the schools put
down and parents are showing a little
work
oh you think we're gonna see a spike in
teen pregnancy i do
yeah that's what i'm talking about if
mom and dad are at work
oh yeah that's true i guess oh yeah if
they're going to work now suddenly oh
yeah the teens have been raring to go
oh yeah yeah oh that was the most fun
dude
i mean not trying to be pregnant but
just like when you were a teen that was
like
fun trying to sneak around and be
naughty yeah yeah
exactly my uh a lot of my friends at
work are basically just like
it's insane here so stay out as long as
you can
avoid it yeah well he just he
he sent this video and it was really
sweet and he just you know said to just
nice things about you just you know
obviously really loves you and um
and so yeah we just wanted to do
something nice we just wanted to send a
thousand bucks so you and uh
the kiddo could go do something fun
sometime since especially since you're
out of work it'd be nice you could just
go do maybe like um
i don't know what's open over there by
you guys
things are starting to reopen um i've
been
kind of waiting for disneyland or
something like that to open so i can
take she's never gone there so maybe
that's insane maybe we could do that
then when they open
yeah that sounds perfect actually that'd
be great do you guys live
you guys live in california yeah i'm in
ventura a little north from l.a
oh yeah yeah that's nice over there it's
pretty nice
it's yeah nice little little beach spot
kind of gets away from the
la hustle and bustle groovy and how uh
and he said you've been in radiation or
something what's going on with it
so i um in july
last summer i was diagnosed with breast
cancer
um so i went through
i had to have a surgery it was stage
four already so there's a little spot on
my
liver that they took out and then i went
through six months of
chemo um and then i just two weeks ago
had surgery
double mastectomy was having lymph nodes
taken out and then in a couple weeks i
will start
radiation and then i just found out that
some of the cancer had
some other type of cancer within
the there was her two positive cells
that they didn't know about so now i'll
start a year of
immunotherapy and all that good stuff
and then
yeah it's been quite quite a fun quite a
year
it sounds like it what do you think
caused it do you know do you think like
it could have
anything like kind of rung a bell you
think when you think back on it
i mean i don't know like
i don't have any there's no family
history i'm
i was 30 when i found it um
i have i mean maybe lifestyle
you know i don't know yeah trust me i
know if that's the case dude i got it
right here
lifestyle choices i could see it
so yeah well it must have been a hell of
a lifestyle if you got that much of it
in your system
last night i'm like how really
did this show up at me if i'm
three and it's day four like god what
did i do it's that bad
oh man well dang that's so crazy well i
hope you feel better whenever i get um
up there to oxnard is close to you guys
right
oh yeah right next to us oh sweet when i
come up there uh maybe later this year
you guys have to come out to a show
sometime
i would freaking love that we actually
saw you a couple summers ago
um we went down to where we were at the
comedy store yeah we're at the comedy
store so are you there
there's awesome i'm a huge fan oh let's
start with you
yeah oh that's awesome yeah yeah thanks
no that'd be awesome um
well look thank dalton whenever you talk
to him and and we'll thank him too and
um
and yeah we just want to send just a
little bit a little gift you guys can go
do something fun especially when
disneyland opens up that would be
probably pretty sweet
so that's amazing well i just thought it
was so nice of him he just left such a
nice message you know it's uh
it's just nice when people just kind of
share how they feel about other people
you know it's like
hell yeah we all need to hear it you
know yeah
i'm gonna have to make him let me listen
to it
well look if you've done some other
things in your life you could definitely
listen to this podcast that's for sure
okay
you'll be fine you'll be fine um
well uh well take care and uh and thanks
for making me laugh
you're welcome you are very welcome all
right give dalton a hug for us
you bet alex y'all have a good one i
will you too
thank you bye-bye
damn do i say bye-bye at the end oh
jesus christ
man what are you doing dude what are you
freaking
doing man bye bye
ah just say bye yeah
hey thank you anything like that man
oh that sounds perfect yep definitely
we'll chat soon
any of those are good options bye bye
bye bye ah
oh man man she sounds so sweet huh
isn't it what man it's so wild how life
picks and chooses and how the world
picks and chooses certain things you
know
and who has to battle something who
doesn't and how we feel about it
i could have talked to two people i i
could have talked to 2 000 people today
that are doing great that are just move
like who are moving into a new house or
doing you know
or just got a a b on their paper or a b
minus even or c plus or anything and
and they wouldn't have been stoked you
know
and here you got alex and she's feeling
stoked man
um it's just a reminder it's just that
equalizer
you know it makes me wonder what life is
what it all what you know what it is
what are we doing out here
because the the biggest moments really i
find i find
you know i get a lot of joy when i do
things like a roller coaster
or if you touch a little titty for the
first time that early titty
but outside of that
and actually riding in the back of a
truck is fun sometimes when you're young
feeling that wind on you and just
feeling like
anything's possible you know going
sky diving is fun it feels good
you know even busting down a little gram
every now and then if you had to when
you was you know
a child or something doing you know
getting a buzz or doing a cigarette
but as i get older really the thing that
makes me
feel a little good is just that what
just that one moment of spark
or just that thing when people are just
being honest saying hey you know i'm
just a human
living thing and
this is who i'm proud of this is how i'm
feeling this is what's going on
you know i want to say i want to take
one moment out of my lifetime
to throw a little bit of homage to my
sister who's had a tough go
and just let her know how much i love
her you know let's just let her know
that i think about her when she's not
around let her know that she means
something to me
you know we have a you know especially i
know people understand that have
struggled and people
we all i think we all just have a human
desire we want to know that we're being
thought of
or if we want to know that we people
care when we're not around you know we
talked about it on here before
you know i think we all do so just a
nice display of that
nice to see that man that's where i find
god right there man
that's really that's really where i find
god um
oh you know what
how am i gonna top that
how am i gonna top that i don't think i
think we're okay
we'll be good for another week if you
got some exciting tick tocks or things
you think we should discuss we want to
try and get a little more visual on the
program
i want to thank dalton for his
submission for his sister
uh i want to thank zachary from uh
illinois looking for the senior quote
um we got some other calls that came in
and we'll get to them next week and
we just want to wish you well alex
we want to just let you know you gotta
just hundreds of thousands of new people
that are just cheering for you
and thinking of you and uh yeah that'd
be fun when i come up there i'm looking
to start a new tour actually towards the
end of the year
so we'll get into some of that later um
you know a lot of neat things i gotta go
get them groceries man
and see what it feels like to be in a
dang new place it sounds scary huh
remember and it's also hard to remember
where the light switches are
that kind of stuff just a lot of
acclimation
so but uh but thank you
uh dawn for the nomination yeah we want
to do just send you a nice gift alex and
i hope you go have fun
um when the world opens up for you and
your little girl man and i just
you know i remember when my sister had
her first baby and
you know that little girl is 12 now i
think and man she just still means the
world to me and
um and the bond that that creates
between
uh siblings when some one of them have a
child it's just real special
and uh just glad to be reminded of that
today
of what that connection piece is you
know praise god baby ptl
right a lot um
all right let's go out uh
just how i get that feeling sometimes
you gotta get it man one person i know
that always uh
helps me get there larry fleet where i
find god
happy st paddy's man
he paid my tab and put me in a cab
but he didn't have to as he could see
i was hurting
oh i wish i'd got his name
cause i didn't feel worth saving
but he saved me just the same shout out
sherlock and yard boy
and pop
day out on
for making this episode
like this
come on
sometimes
i don't know what they're saying
but it sounds like a him to me come on
but thanks for everything let's go lara
bear come on
me and him just riding around sometimes
that's where
while i do that
that's where i find god
um i said hitter baby man that really is
that hitter right there
uh thank you nick and sean and colin
uh producers and associate producers for
helping me put together an episode today
thank you for for everybody that listens
to the podcast man
and uh and is a part of our lives and uh
for letting us be a part of yours um you
guys be good to yourself
you deserve it okay